in this video we're going to talk about
ideal gases and how we can describe
what's going on with them so the first
question you might be wondering is what
is an ideal gas and it really is a bit
of a theoretical construct that helps us
describe a lot of what's going on in the
gas world or at least close to what's
going on in the gas world so in an ideal
gas we imagine that the individual
particles of the gas don't interact so
particles
particles don't
interact
and obviously we know that's not
generally true there's generally some
light intermolecular forces as they get
close to each other as they pass by each
other or if they collide into each other
but for the sake of what we're going to
study in this video we'll assume that
they don't interact and we'll also
assume that the particles don't take up
any volume
don't
take
up
volume
now we know that that isn't exactly true
that individual molecules of course do
take up volume but this is a reasonable
assumption because generally speaking it
might be a very very infinitesimally
small fraction of the total volume of
the space that they are bouncing around
in and so these are the two assumptions
we make when we talk about ideal gases
that's why we're using the word ideal in
future videos we'll talk about non-ideal
behavior but allows us to make some
simplifications that approximate a lot
of the world so let's think about how we
can describe ideal gases we can think
about the volume of the container that
they are in
we can imagine the pressure that they
would exert on say the inside of the
container that's how i visualize it
although that pressure would be the same
at any point inside of the container we
can think about the temperature and we
want to do it an absolute scale so we
generally measure temperature in kelvin
and then we can also think about just
how much of that gas we have and we can
measure that in terms of number of moles
and so that's what this lowercase n is
so let's think about how these four
things can relate to each other
so let's just always put volume on the
left hand side how does volume relate to
pressure well what i imagine is if i
have a balloon like this
and i have some gas in the balloon
if i try to decrease the volume by
making it a smaller balloon without
letting out any other air or without
changing the temperature so i'm not
changing t and n what's going to happen
to the pressure
well that gas is going to per square
inch or per square area exert more and
more force it gets harder and harder for
me to squeeze that balloon
so as volume goes down pressure goes up
or likewise if i were to make the
container bigger not changing once again
the temperature or the number of moles i
have inside of the container it's going
to lower the pressure so it looks like
volume and pressure move inversely with
each other so what we could say is that
volume is proportional to
1 over pressure
the inverse of pressure or you could say
that pressure is proportional to the
inverse of volume this just means
proportional to which means that volume
would be equal to some constant divided
by pressure in this case
now how does volume
relate to temperature
well if i start with my balloon example
and you could run this example if if you
don't believe me
if you take a balloon and you were to
blow it up at room temperature and then
if you were to put it into the fridge
you should see what happens
it's going to shrink and you might say
why is it shrinking well you could
imagine that the particles inside the
blue are a little less vigorous at that
point
they have lower individual kinetic
energies and so in order for them to
exert the same pressure to offset
atmospheric pressure on the outside you
are going to have a lower volume
and so volume you could say is
proportional to
temperature now how does volume compare
to number of moles
well think about it if you blow air into
a balloon you're putting more moles into
that balloon and holding pressure and
temperature constant you are going to
increase the volume so volume is
proportional to the number of moles if
you were to take air out you're also
going to decrease the volume keeping
pressure and temperature constant
so we can use these three relationships
and these are actually known as this
first one is known as boyle's law this
is charles's law this is avogadro's law
but you can combine them to realize that
volume is going to be proportional to
the number of moles
times the
temperature divided by the pressure
divided by
the pressure
or another way to say it is you could
say that volume is going to be equal to
some constant that's what
proportionality is just talking about
it's going to be equal to some constant
let's call it r times all of this
business r
n
t
over p
over
p
or another way to think about it is we
can multiply both sides by p and what
will you get we will get p
times
v
and this might be looking somewhat
familiar to some of you
is equal to and i'll just change the
order right over here
n
which is the number of moles
times some constant
times
t
our temperature measured in kelvin and
this relationship right over here pv is
equal to nrt is one of the most useful
things in chemistry and it's known as
the ideal gas law and in future videos
we're going to apply it over and over
again to see how useful it is
now one question you might be wondering
is what is this constant it's known as
the ideal gas constant and you can look
it up but it's going to be dependent on
what units you use for pressure volume
and temperature and we will see that in
future videos